florian rousseau est de retour la
fédération française de cyclisme huit
ans après avoir quitté son poste
d'entraîneur national
le pistard vient d'être nommé directeur
du programme olympique par la ffc il
aura pour objectif de partager son
expérience internationale et son vécu
sur les jo avec notamment trois titres
olympiques
mon rôle c'est d'animer de coordonner en
tout cas est de fixer un cap en
notamment par rapport aux objectifs de
réussite donc deux médailles aux jeux en
paris 2024 d'identifier les besoins pour
accompagner les entraîneurs les acteurs
de la terre et des athlètes florian
rousseau aura deux ans et demi pour
remobiliser un groupe france fragilisée
après les jeux olympiques 2021 raté avec
seulement deux médailles de bronze en
cyclisme toutes disciplines confondues
la plus value est vraiment transformé
l'essai lors des jeux olympiques pour ça
évidemment il va construire son approche
il va la construire avec l'encadrement
ils à mettre en place une équipe pour
gérer tous les aspects qui lui semble
important autour de la performance c'est
plein d'éléments qui viennent s'agréger
les uns aux autres et c'est tout ce
travail de construction qui doit
l'amener à faire en sorte que à paris
2024 bon soit dans une configuration où
on confirme finalement les résultats
qu'on a dans les grands championnats
internationaux
ce mercredi 3 novembre au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
fédération française espère débuter une
nouvelle ère avec peut-être avec les
plusieurs titres olympiques en 2024 sur
le territoire évinois en bmx cyclisme
sur piste ou encore vtt